hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video and today we're gonna be doing
something a little bit different today
is my first of Borderlands 3 video ever
since release I've been grinding this
game I'm right a little 46 with Amara I
think my guardian rank is like 20 right
now so I've been playing constantly
since released one of my all-time
favorite series but as I was grinding
today I actually found a very weird
weapon that is a reference to another
game as you may have noticed in the
title and I kind of want to talk about
it share some of my thoughts maybe this
will be a decent weapon and one of your
builds or stuff like that so as always
like to be if you do enjoy guys
subscribe if you're new my Twitter and
discord will be in the description down
below and let's get started with today's
video so the weapon I found is the speed
loading hell Walker at level 45 it is a
legendary elemental shotgun with it
being flame at least as the one that I
picked up now I'm assuming you
understand as we go a little bit through
the weapon I'm assuming this is going to
be an only elemental in terms of fire
type of element shotgun I don't think
it's going to be anything else
you understand why in a sec the item
score was 476 and I got this at around
level 45 so pretty close to the end of
the game so roughly this damage may
fluctuate but probably not in crazy
amounts for this the damage was 347
times 10 making that 3470 54 percent
accuracy 51 percent handling a reload
time of one second four point twenty
seconds of fire rate and a magazine size
of two and mine came with four hundred
and thirty seven damage per second
aflame with a four percent chance of it
knocking the opponent into some
elemental status effect but with the
fact that I'm using Amara as you'll see
in the gameplay I'm knocking these
people into the status effect the whole
time just because of the way that my
build has been shaping so really that
four percent means fuck-all to me bread
flavor tech says so my demons your time
has come a 57 percent weapon damage 10
percent critical hit damage a 35 percent
reload speed it consumes 2 ml per shots
are gonna be shooting and then reloading
immediately and of course it's highly
effective against flesh because it is a
flame weapon and this one in particular
was anointed meaning it is just a
general type of skill base so on this
one it says on skill an action skill and
a weapon status effect damage are and
chances are increased by 70
percent for a short time and it is a
Jacob's shotgun which is always my
favorite shot the Jacob's family and if
you're not really understanding by the
title on what I've just explained to you
this is the doom elemental fire shotgun
and now that's what I mean why I think
this weapon is only going to be a fire
weapon because doom with hell and all
the dirt and all that demon and stuff it
just makes a whole lot of sense that
this would be a flame only shotgun I'll
show a little bit of gameplay in the
background currently the gameplay is on
Normal difficulty and we're on mayhem
too I thought I'd get a little bit risky
playing up on the upper mayhem
difficulties I'm definitely very
confident and then mayhem one but mayhem
two and three are a little bit risky I
need to get a little bit more better
gear and kind of min/max my build a
little bit and definitely respect as my
stats are absolutely terrible definitely
trying to work on getting a fully
elemental amara build so let me know if
you guys want to see that because
honestly Mars one of my favorite
characters if not be favorite character
out of the four in Borderlands 3 now you
are probably wondering how to get this
weapon and don't worry I'll let you know
right now be aware there are minor
spoilers for the boss that I was farming
so if you haven't gotten to the planet
that I'm currently on or you haven't
gotten very far into the game I highly
recommend you come back at a later date
and then come back to this video and
then you can watch it just because I
don't want to ruin the story for you
because goddamn is this story a good one
but the boss that I was farming is grave
mine grave manned grave ward something
like that grave board I believe is his
name you've probably seen this in a lot
of other popular borderlands 3 content
creator videos it's the same exact
process there's a quest that claptrap
will give you after you complete
reliance which is basically when you do
all the quests with clay as soon as you
meet bay looks for the first time you
know that you've been completely
successful in doing all of clays quest
for reliance once you go back to
claptrap in sanctuary 3 he will then
give you a quest called something of
Raiders of the Lost Rock and you talk to
this guy and he will have you do a bunch
of rock quest and he will give you
something like the porcelain pipe bomb
this weapon in grenade is [ __ ] broken
and can absolutely destroy this easy
vault monster in about 10 seconds as
you'll see on screen I did [ __ ] up
during the gameplay but of course as you
can tell like that health difference
from when he was at full to like half or
something that's disgusting right and it
can get even better if you don't [ __ ] up
the throw like I did and even if you
didn't oh why you de or a butcher can
completely melt as health as you're
seeing here
I got that done it may be 20 or 30
seconds so easy sweep after a couple
hours of just grinding just trying to
get Guardian levels I've ended up
finding coming across this weapon now
there's no confirmation on whether this
is a dedicated drop for grave Ward I
don't believe it is because this took me
two hours of like constant farming back
and forth and I finally got this is the
first time I've ever seen this weapon or
I've seen a bunch of other weapons
beforehand so I'm thinking this is
either a guaranteed drop for another
boss in the game or this is just part of
the general legendary loop pool part of
the general legendary loophole still
nothing wrong with farming grave Ward
Singh is seeing as he's one of the
easiest bosses in the game especially
with this new exploit and on top of
getting so much more XP but if you find
a faster way in your opinion or if you
want to go for loot midgets that's
totally fine too all options are
definitely accessible but if you have
found him or if you have found this
weapon somewhere and buy some other boss
never let me know in the comments below
and I'll update that in a pin comment so
that people understand and find other
bosses that they want to farm with
overall for my thoughts on the weapon
the weapon honestly isn't that bad
actually I thought it was gonna be
pretty shitty of course it is a fire
weapon so shields are gonna be pretty
tanky against this thing but if you can
find an enemy that has no shields or if
you manage to get the shield off of an
opponent they will easily get melted by
the shotgun maybe two hits at most and
they'll be completely [ __ ] I was I
mean as you'll see in the gameplay I was
clapping a badass Goliath with obviously
no shield and within seconds he was gone
I did go down a bit but I did absolutely
smoked him with this gun it is a very
deadly weapon for sure if you are gonna
carry this weapon in your main loadout I
do recommend having some type of shock
weapon with you whether that be a
grenade a other weapon in general or
something definitely keep that on hand
because the shotgun isn't going to doom
isn't going to be your major damage
dealer through those shields because of
course it's flame and it's very
effective against flesh and not shields
yeah let me know what you guys think of
that down in the comments below I got
some other ideas for Borderlands content
if I come through any other VIP ins like
these you know random references and
stuff like that I will definitely put
those into a video but I have an idea of
getting all the crew challenges moxie
sabotage radios claptraps friend that
he's trying to make all that other stuff
like zeros kill counters and the big
game hunts for sir hammerlock I'm gonna
see what those rewards are at the end of
the game I'm very curious because I
haven't gotten all of them yet but I'm
very
close to all of them so I definitely
want to know if there's some type of
reward I'll plant I'm making two videos
for each of those topics one showing off
the reward and then one showing off all
the locations so you know exactly where
to go if you want to find those items
but that guys like the V if you do enjoy
subscribe renew thank you guys for
coming to this new content I know it's a
little bit rocky doing some different
types of content it's always scary for a
content creator to do such a thing like
this so hoping it does well I love
Borderlands love the series so I
definitely want to start making a lot
more content for this game since it is
very fun and I guys take care of girls
today and peace out
[Music]
you
[Music]